Yunis fossil was 15 when ISIL fighters
accused him of stealing they dragged him
to a public square and chopped off his
right hand in front of a crowd Yunus
says he wasn't stealing simply helping
his uncle move furniture after ISIL
seized his home I can't remember what
happened they blindfolded me and gave me
painkillers beforehand afterward the
pain was awful I don't see any future
when they cut my hand they cut my
ability to work - marry your earlier his
brother Ezell Dean was shot three times
by ISIL fighters that was punishment for
earning less than five dollars a night
while looking after a car park without
permission he says to hospitals refused
to treat him because ISIL ordered
doctors not to he's paralyzed and hooked
to a colostomy bag if the family could
have afforded to celebrate the death of
Abu Bakr al-baghdadi they say they would
have and it would have surpassed any
Muslim holiday feast but the death of
the former ISIL leader brings fleeting
solace my situation is worse than my
brother I have no help I'm depressed I
put my life in God's hands in the two
years since ISIL was defeated in Mosul
people have continued to struggle more
than three hundred thousand are still
displaced fifty-three thousand homes
flattened people feel abandoned by the
government and they're angry the
brothers mother has been trying to get
the Iraqi government to provide
disability and health care to her sons
for two years like others we interviewed
the family members say they've
encountered one bureaucratic obstacle
after another just about everyone here
seems to be scarred by isil's atrocities
even with Baghdadi dead and ISIL
so-called Caliphate a memory Iraqis in
Mosul we met say they
mein imprisoned by bleak living
conditions
Natacha guy named Al Jazira Mosul Iraq